bonjour patrick ferrasse merci de
répondre à nos questions cet après midi
sur arte france
le premier ministre a bien remède évoque
une première tentative d' élections
libres
mais dans certaines régions des partis
d'opposition ont appelé au boycott
quid de la légitimité de ce double
scrutin ce sera assez difficile si l'on
peut dire parce que comme vous venez de
souligner il ya quelques partis
d'opposition qui ne veulent pas jouer le
jeu électoral pour plein de raisons
certains ont leurs leaders qui sont
emprisonnés si l'on peut dire et
d'autres s'opposent carrément premier
ministre mais au-delà de cela vous avez
aussi des problèmes de sécurité dans
énormément de région en ethiopie ce qui
fait que les élections ne pourra pas
avoir lieu et seront replanifier si l'on
peut dire en septembre juste avant la
réunion du parlement qui décidera du
premier ministre et en même temps vous
avez la raison du tigre allez vous avez
montré dans votre votre séquence vidéo
un petit peu avant le conflit
extrêmement important qui fait que 6% de
la population aujourd'hui en ethiopie ne
pourra pas voter
voilà donc ça fait énormément de 2,2
points noirs si l'on peut dire dans une
légitimité du premier ministre il est
évident que le son parti le parti de la
prospérité qui succède à la coalition
pour voir qui était jusqu'en 2018 on
pouvoir devrait remporter ces élections
mais ça fait quand même quelques taches
noires sur le sur le fond si l'on peut
dire et on aura du mal à voir une
réconciliation nationale une unité
nationale qui la voudrait avec six trous
dans la raquette
selon les résultats de ces élections est
ce qu'on peut craindre un regain de
tensions dans certaines régions
notamment dans le tigré je pense pâture
à un regain de tensions durent élections
il ya les tensions dans certaines
régions qui continueront ça c'est sûr où
la police fédérale où l'armée est déjà
déployée pour tenter d'y mettre fin ils
sont à dire la région du tigre haye
comme vous l'avez dit aussi tout à
l'heure le conflit a été rapide annoncée
comme rapide par le premier ministre est
finie au 28 novembre
non c'est bien qu'aujourd'hui les
combats ont encore lieu et c'est ce qui
fait que l'aide humanitaire ne peut pas
être déployés et que la famine et les
exactions qui ont été commises sont
flagrantes si l'on peut dire donc non il
n'y aura pas de regain de tensions
puisque cela en gentil g et l'argent
tiré il reste toujours une région où les
leaders du tplf le prend de libération
du tigre à y sont toujours dans la dent
dans le bush dans le cas précis on peut
dire pour faire la guerre et s'opposer à
ce gouvernement de transition qui leur
était imposé
justement dans cette région aux grains
aucune date n'a été pour le moment fixée
la situation reste très préoccupante on
l'a dit vous avez dit les combats
continuent l'onu a tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé
cette région est ce qu'au final c'est le
plus grand défi du premier ministre
habib rahman
ça sera un des grands défis de la bia
med avec la situation économique qui
n'est pas florissante si l'on peut lire
tous les autres foyers d'insécurité
qu'il va falloir résoudre ça fait
plusieurs petits foyers donc des
déploiements de forces et l'armée qui
être pour 50% utilisé dans le tigre est
aujourd'hui n'a pas les moyens de faire
la totalité de la sécurité du pays
donc mais c'est le plus gros point noir
parce qu'il va falloir rappeler il le
fera quand même tendre la main aux
tigres et un moment où l'autre pour
simplement travailler sur la
réconciliation nationale et vous pouvez
pas parler d'unités si vous mettez de
côté 6% de la population
donc il faudra un moment ou un autre
voire les tigres est autrement que par
le gouvernement de transition qui
devrait être imposé aujourd'hui
donc tout ça veut dire que redéfinir une
vie politique dans cette région
et là on est dans un espace temps d'au
moins 5 ans avant de créer des
atmosphères où on puisse avoir un parti
politique des gens qui vont voter pour
ces partis politiques et qui sont
complètement libre donc là on est dans
un espace temps long ce qui veut dire
que ce qui va arriver demain au premier
ministre qui déjà 1er extrait puis trois
ans ainsi une meilleure légitimité si
l'on peut dire
mais il va continuer à dérouler son
programme et il va falloir qu'ils se
trouvent des solutions à toute cette
insécurité au tigre est aussi dans notre
région et en même temps essayer de
relancer l'économie éthiopienne et quel
impact au-delà des frontières même de
l'ethiopie alors que ce pays
un important poids diplomatique on le
sait dans la région à addis abeba qui
fournit par exemple des soldats de
maintien de la paix en somalie au sud ou
encore au soudan au delà des seuls
problèmes frontaliers que l'on peut voir
au niveau de la corne de l'afrique c'est
avec les vitrines liste l'erythrée a été
invité à parler studio tient à venir
traiter le problème de la région du
tigre haye ce qui fait que ce n'est pas
un problème souvent été national comme
cela avait été annoncé au départ
donc on a bien là une intervention d'un
pays tiers à la demande des éthiopiens
donc c'est pas très sain niveau de la de
la stabilité de la région
après le reste sur des troupes de
maintien de la paix sous l'égide du haut
pays participe parce que ça leur fait
une renommée internationale qui compte
que très connue depuis très longtemps il
était jusqu'à il ya un an et demi le
premier contributeur des forces
maintient la paix des nations unies au
niveau mondial sont pris ils sont
aujourd'hui dos 3e derrière le rwanda
mais c'est quand même une grande force
de maintien de la paix qui déploie un
petit peu partout mais c'est aussi pour
la stabilité de la région ils peuvent
pas s'en retirer peuvent pas se retirer
du soudan ne peut pas se retirer de la
somalie ainsi de suite parce que c'est
quand même la stabilité à la frontière
qu'il est recherché
donc c'est du maintien de la paix des
nations unies mais c'est aussi pour
permettre à l'ethiopie pays enclavé de
sortir si l'on peut dire du marasme
économique
et puis de devenir un poids comme les
dix premiers ministres un poids dans la
corne de l'afrique mais qu'elle n'a plus
beaucoup aujourd'hui et tel regarde la
communauté internationale sur ces
élections
l'union européenne envoie pas
d'observateurs les états unis sont
méfiants je crois que c'est ça l'union
africaine va déployer quelques quêtes et
observateurs mais bon c'est ken ça ne
pèse pas lourd si l'on peut dire
aujourd'hui ils ont tenté une médiation
sur ce conflit du tigre et se sont fait
renvoyer dans leurs buts
personne n'y prête pas trop attention
quoi donc aujourd'hui il ya quand même
une certaine méfiance de la police
nationale vis à vis ces élections tout
simplement parce que les américains
étaient des leaders dans
l'offensive de dire voilà maintenant
faut qu'on arrête confie aux tigres il
faut que l'aide humanitaire arrive donc
si vous regardez bien ces les etats-unis
ont lancé un petit peu le mouvement si
l'on peut dire les nations unies comme
l'union européenne sont quand même assez
frileux ce pilote pardon merci patrick
ferrasse d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
stratégie africaine spécialiste de la
corne de l'afrique